Es braucht viel Fingerspitzengefühl,
um die empfindlichen weißen Stangen aus
der Erde zu stechen.
Kilometerweit erstrecken sich die
foliengeschützen Spargelfelder
hier im ostdeutschen Beelitz.
Der Spargelhof von Familie Jakobs ist im
Frühling ein beliebtes Ausflugsziel.
Viele Besucher wollen das Gemüse gleich
erntefrisch kaufen.
Auch das gehört zum Kult um den Spargel.
Wenn das frische Grün rauskommt, wenn die
ersten Tulpen blühen,
dann ist auch Spargelzeit.
Und man fährt durch die Gegend, überall
sieht man die Spargelfelder und denkt:
Bald ist wieder Spargel[zeit].
Das Wort alleine – „Spargel“ – schon, das
zergeht einem auf der Zunge.
Eine Delikatesse, kann man sagen, ja.
Und ... das sind [ist] typisch für Deutschland,
ich weiß das, ja.
Und dann ... wir sind sehr froh, hier zu sein
und dann Spargel zu essen
und [zu] genießen, ja.
Die Deutschen sind Spargel-Europameister
beim Anbau.
Und auch beim Verzehr liegen sie weit vorn:
Pro Saison isst jeder Deutsche
durchschnittlich 1,5 Kilogramm
des Edelgemüses.
Mit dem aufkommenden Wohlstand in den
60er-Jahren
ist auch ein neues Spargelwirtschaftswunder
entstanden.
Und wir haben heute eine
Pro-Kopf-Produktion und auch einen
Pro-Kopf-Konsum, wie wir ihn noch nie
hatten.
Für mich ist Spargel deshalb Kulturgut,
weil es – wie gesagt – nicht gerade
eine neue ... eine Modeerscheinung ist,
dass jetzt gerade mal Spargel gegessen wird,
sondern dass natürlich schon
seit dem Mittelalter in den Klostergärten, an
den Königshäusern Spargel verzehrt wurde.
In der Region von Beelitz wird seit 1861
Spargel angebaut:
zehn Prozent grüner Spargel, der oberhalb
der Erde wächst,
und 90 Prozent weißer, der unter der Erde
gedeiht.
Sobald er mit Licht in Kontakt kommt, verfärbt
sich Spargel.
Das „Gemüse der Könige“ musste immer
schon weiß sein und kerzengerade.
Der Spargel würde auch mal eine leichte
Krümmung haben,
aber wir suchen natürlich schon Flächen aus.
Das sind hier sandige Flächen.
Das sieht man auch, wenn man den Boden
mal nimmt, ja?
Das ist purer Sand. Und in diesem Sand ...
in diesem Sand wächst der Spargel möglichst
gerade und hat keinen Widerstand.
Und weil der auch ’n leichtes ... Der Boden
erwärmt sich gut
und dadurch kriegt der Spargel auch hier sein
einzigartiges Aroma.
Man geht mit dem Messer an dem Spargel
runter, sticht ihn ab, holt ihn raus ...
Er ist leichter zu ernten, wenn sein Kopf
schon aus der Erde guckt.
Spezielle Planen schützen ihn vor Licht.
Und natürlich kommt das Gemüse auf dem
Spargelhof
in vielen Variationen auf den Tisch:
bodenständig mit Schnitzel, im Crêpeteig, als
Auflauf
oder klassisch mit Kartoffeln und Sauce
Hollandaise.
Wie man aus fein geschältem Spargel Haute
Cuisine macht, zeigt Michael Kempf.
Der Chefkoch aus dem Berliner
Zweisterne-Restaurant „Facil“
vermischt Spargel mit Himbeeren und
Paprika.
Ich entwickle den Spargel weiter:
Ich möchte jetzt den Spargel haben und der
bekommt ein komplettes Gericht umstellt.
Und die Beilagen, Garnituren und Saucen
dürfen den Spargel nicht übertönen.
Der Spargel ist dann der König auf dem
Teller.
Am liebsten brät er Spargel in der Pfanne.
Wenn er ihn kocht, dann mit Prisen von Salz
und braunem Zucker,
zusammen mit Zitronenscheiben und etwas
Butter – so kurz wie möglich.
Bei manchen Gerichten im Restaurant „Facil“
werden aber auch
weißer und grüner Spargel kombiniert, wie
zum Beispiel bei diesem Spargelsalat.
Ich finde den weißen sehr elegant,
mit zurückhaltender Bitternote,
und der grüne ist eher brachialer, sehr mutig.
Doch wie ist es um die Zukunft des weißen
Spargels bestellt?
Lohnkosten machen bei uns über 50 Prozent
der Gesamtkosten aus und
wenn die jetzt überproportional steigen,
kann es passieren,
dass der Spargel wieder deutlich elitärer wird,
so wie es im 17./18.Jahrhundert mal war.
Vitaminreich, kalorienarm und mit einem
ganz eigenen, feinen Geschmack –
der weiße Spargel ist – zumindest noch –
das Frühlingsgemüse Nummer eins in
Deutschland.